continuer à avancer
après avoir tout perdu adam
depuis trois mois anna polanska ya une
rescapée de boudhha s'accroche à la vie
une semaine après l'invasion russe en
ukraine sa décision est prise il faut
partir
anna alors enceinte de cinq mois son
mari anton et leur chienne beach cas en
barque dans la voiture
loin de trouver leur salut dans la fuite
il croise un charrues
après cinq minutes ils ont été attaqués
son mari est mort sur le coup et l'a vu
mourir
voici ce qui reste de leur voiture les
impacts des balles malgré des drapeaux
blancs la vie d'anna a basculé dans
l'horreur atteint au bas du dos elle
perd momentanément l' usage de ses
jambes et quelques semaines plus tard
elle perd son bébé sur une table
d'opération
et
titre
de son ancienne vie il ne reste que sa
chienne times gâte
c'est en sécurité chez une infirmière
qui avait soigné un a lors de son
passage à l'hôpital de vivre nous dit
elle
anna est rescapé d'un crime de guerre
elle ne rate aucune occasion d'en
témoigner comme à pâques avec le maire
de bruxelles philippe close de passage
en ukraine
son récit on est un parmi des milliers
crimes de guerre crimes contre
l'humanité ou même génocide la cour
pénale internationale et départ des
états et des ong veut documenter les
exactions russes commises sur le vaste
territoire du cren ça ne vais pas ce
réel ce qu'ils ont vécu la députée
libérale paul robitaille revient sur sa
récente mission au pays on la communauté
internationale doit être vigilante doit
dénoncer doit publier tout ce qu'elle a
même si les procès vont prendre du temps
on a essayé de recueillir la preuve
qu'on trouvait sur le terrain il y avait
plein de choses que les militaires ont
laissé derrière eux qu'on a gardé qu'on
a mis dans des sacs et qu'on a bien
répertorié les témoignages recueillis se
ressemblent c'est un modus operandi
qu'on a vu un peu partout c'est à dire
les gruss arrive et là ils tirent sur
les civils
il instaure un espèce de deux stations
de terres rares un sentiment de terreur
le mari d'anna a été enterré sans elle
la semaine dernière à zaporizhya sa
ville natale elle a aussi appris que son
appartement a été détruit par les russes
et là tout perdu sauf sa résilience
parce qu'après avoir frôlé la mort elle
sait que chaque pas qu'il fera dans la
vie relèvera du miracle nooja
siamo
noi
sunshine
un rappel qu'il ne faut rien tenir pour
acquis surtout pas la liberté
ici s mitraillette radio canada montréal
[Musique]